[Music]
you guys it's been a crazy week in
america let's find out what happened
the oscars were held on sunday
and they were held like this
after will smith slapped chris rock
during sunday's oscar ceremony the
academy of motion picture arts and
sciences said that it does not condone
violence but then they saw the ratings
and added
[Applause]
jane campion won the oscar for best
director this weekend and brought a
piece of paper on stage with her when
she gave her acceptance speech and this
is cool we found a photo of it
she did it
she did it did it she did it
lots of people need to keep that in
their pocket yes they do
matter of fact i got right
mine is the same but it the don't is
crossed out
you guys a federal judge in california
said this week that he believed it was
likely that former president trump and
one of his lawyers conspired to defraud
the united states over the 2020 election
you can read all about it in dub [ __ ]
magazine
that wasn't me calling someone a [ __ ]
that was the magnet that's the message
the title of the match the magazine also
you don't subscribe they subscribe to
you
you open up your mailbox all right
oh what's this note don't act crazy
it was announced this week that
scientists have created a non-hormonal
birth control pill for men that they
believe in is 99 effective and because
it is non-hormonal they believe it will
have no side effects now i understand
men might be nervous to try a new drug
like this so i put together a comparison
of the possible side effects of women's
birth control versus this new man's
birth control to see if it's actually
worth the risk here are the side effects
of women's birth control
nausea sore breasts early period late
period no period constant period heavy
period a blood flood spotting brown
discharge ruined panties ruined pants
ruined sheets why is this happening
trouble breathing barely breathing by
dunking sheep chest pain is it a heart
attack maybe probably definitely ow achy
soreness in your legs achy breaky heart
sudden headaches frequent headaches
constant headaches aura what is that
flashes of lights do not follow it
zigzag lines blind spots a field of
vision that looks like a heat wave you
are in hell an inability to judge
distances foggy vision fractured vision
tunnel vision is this lsd short-term
blindness jaundice decreased libido then
what's the point depression jokes on you
had that already weight gain acne facial
hair oily skin mood changes sweet death
and just a little hangry
[Music]
and
here are the side effects of men's birth
control
it's not chewable
[Applause]
[Music]
enlightening
uh different factors you gotta weigh
there is a lot i don't know so men
please consult with your physician to
see if the risk is even worth it for you
back to the monologue
in an effort to save money on gas a
massachusetts man recently began riding
an electric unicycle to his job and it
was going great until his co-workers
wanted to carpool
he was crushed to death
[Music]
i made up the last part the first part
was real the last part was made up
or was it or was it oh no
he could be underneath four people so if
you're riding a unicycle you deserve to
be crushed to death i'm sorry
that's right
that's right
i hate unicyclists
you guys you heard it here first wait a
minute eric
anti-unicycle stance wait a second
what's this note don't act crazy
all right yeah yeah
you should have read your note
phone carrier verizon said this week
that bad actors had sent some customers
spam text messages no i didn't said a
bad actor
now when you don't like someone
the nice thing to do is use a flattering
picture of them yeah
never in his life as this man looked
this dude no
no
today was national trombone players day
but i didn't have time to celebrate
[Applause]
the don't is crossed out the don't just
crossed out and finally according to a
recent nbc news poll president biden's
approval rating has fallen to 40 percent
but that's not the furthest he's fallen
psych you think this is a game roll the
clip
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it's the holding onto the back rail for
me
it's like a different kind of gravity
yeah
and that was the monologue did you guys
like the monologue
okay good
if you didn't like it we would have had
to start over
in other news the senate held
confirmation hearings last week for
supreme court nominee katanji brown
jackson unfortunately instead of asking
judge jackson about her impressive work
history many gop senators used the
hearings as an opportunity to push their
political agenda now because judge
jackson is a black woman pursuing the
highest role in our legal system she has
to keep a certain demeanor i on the
other hand am a late night host you can
roast a [ __ ] so
we're going to do just that in a segment
called i'll take this one
[Applause]
[Music]
we will now commence the senate hearing
i'll take the first question can you
provide a definition for the word woman
oh yeah i'll take this one senator
blackburn while you were too busy being
transphobic to even run a come through
your regular here i was preparing for
your nonsense the existence of trans
women is not a threat to anyone but
shout out to you for having the
confidence to think you could pull off
that lip color next question do you
agree with this book that is being
taught with kids that the babies are
racist senator
i'll take this one
you know what children's book i love
the little engine that wishes you would
also what babies are you talking about
that are reading fresh out of the womb
point them out so i can send them to
professor x
i don't know if babies are racist but i
do know that they all hate your beard
next question is it your personal hidden
agenda to incorporate critical race
theory into our legal system
uh i'll i'll take this one if i had a
hidden agenda why the hell would i tell
you what it is
then
it wouldn't be a hidden agenda i mean
the only thing hidden is your lips girl
where is your mouth
i hear you but i can't tell where it's
coming from last question so uh on a
scale of one to ten
how faithful would you say you are
in terms of religion
i'll take this one
it's a 10 because my faith in god has
kept me from jumping across this table
and smacking the hee-haw out your mouth
you look like the keebler elf who failed
out of law school
you sound like a mint julep that came to
life
your old
i do declare looking ass you old
younger brother looking ass you owe
first 10 minutes of benjamin button
looking ass
this has been i'll take this one
there have been a lot of big headlines
lately so here's one smaller bit of news
you might have missed new york city
lifted its coronavirus vaccine mandate
for professional athletes and performers
last week which will allow brooklyn net
star kyrie irving to play in home games
more importantly the new rules allow us
to feature an unvaccinated performer
that we haven't been able to have on the
show until now so without further ado
please welcome for the very first time
our unvaccinated mascot ruffy
[Music]
[Applause]
wow look at
that's right ruffy he's already pumping
up the crowd ruffy dude it's great to
have you back
yeah
and that's my dog he is so much fun say
ruffy i've been meaning to ask you
ruffy how come you didn't get the
vaccine
[Music]
oh raffy you are so silly but seriously
though why didn't you just get it
oh are you saying you were doing your
own research
oh well how'd that go
did you end up catching
covid no don't raise the roof ruffy did
you catch covet or not
oh ruffy was it bad
oh
how bad
is is that a noise meter
are you doing a noise meter with your
arm to tell us the severity of your
covet case
did you have to go to the hospital
oh
ruffy you should have just got the
vaccine bud
well why not
oh
you were afraid
oh it wasn't bad at all ruffy just a
quick shot in the arm and that's it
you still think that it's the kiss of
death
i don't know ruffy i think you're kind
of a conspiracy theorist if you're not
vaccinated i just hope you're at least
wearing a mask under there
you're not well then stop taking selfies
with the audience members you're gonna
make them sick
oh ruffy i'm sorry did i hurt your
feelings
sorry bud i'm just trying to keep
everybody safe you understand right
what has gotten into you
oh you you think the vaccine has altered
my dna
and you think a chip has been implanted
in my brain
no no ruffy don't you try to raise the
roof your way out of this you get out of
here
our unvaccinated mascot revvy everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you